foreign
ER for you all right so I I go to sleep
and I wake up and I say I gotta explain
her I got I got another one so they
haunt me and until I release them in
this medium and then I sleep well at
night okay awesome well let's let's make
sure you get a good night's sleep
tonight all right I'm releasing the
explainer demons the exactly the course
within me this is this is the Neil
deGrasse Tyson we're going to call these
um the Neo melatonin mom moments
melatonin moments you gotta say it right
so
do you know why clocks reckon time
clockwise
yeah is it wait
that's just the way they did it and then
all of a sudden we just started calling
it clockwise
Okay the reason is simple and
complicated at the same time on the
equator
uh the Sun
Rises due east and sets Due West
every day of the year and it is the only
place on Earth where that happens
all right and so the cut and the Sun
Goes High overhead giving literal
meaning to high noon and then as you
hike North
the ark the sun takes in the sky
goes farther and farther south
it's no longer goes directly overhead
it's just that the ark going from east
to west
just just sits lower and lower in the
sky okay until you hit the Arctic Circle
where the sun is like it's practically
horizontal to the Horizon as it goes all
the way around but we're we're here in
New York City where middle latitude so
the sun's path through the sky is sort
of in the meat in between somewhere okay
that means
uh it's basically almost always south of
you
mm-hmm just think about that if on the
equator it's to your left and above your
head and to the right
as you walk North
the sun's Ark
dips behind you and behind you is south
okay okay
it's South
so here's the point in the northern
hemisphere if you were ever facing the
sun you will never be facing north
it is never North
ever this and where does the moss grow
on the tree on the north side of the
tree
right the Sun never hits that side of
these objects in the northern hemisphere
okay in the southern hemisphere it's the
opposite and they would grow moss on
their
southern side
okay
because the sun would always then be
north of where they are and it's fun
when I visit the southern hemisphere I'm
always just rethinking all this it's
just a fun thing to reconstruct the
geometry of Earth in space relative to
the sun all right okay so
civilization as we know it
began in the northern hemisphere what
was the one of the first time keeping
devices people used uh Sundial sundial
so a sundial
has all the hours of the day
on a flat surface
and there's a thing sticking up
that actually has an official word I
would just call it a stick but the
official word is gnomen
with a genome
g-n-o-m-o-n nomen no gloman Okay so
the nomen
when illuminated by the sun cast a
shadow
on these numbers and you calibrate this
depending on what latitude you're in on
Earth's surface
you need a different Sundial if you're
at a different latitude
each sendile only works for one latitude
okay okay
all right
so
picture this
okay I got my sundial
and I got my gnomen
and the Sun
rises in the East
okay and as the sun rises up the Norman
cast a shadow on these hours that are
carved into the brass plate
right and we can ask
what direction does the gnomen shadow
move right yes sundial
gnomen shadow
moves clockwise
there you go
all right all the way until the sun is
in the west and it casts to Shadow far
over on the right hand side of the dial
if you're facing facing south well and
then night time comes and no men knows
what time it is
look I mean facing north in my example
that's right so so sundials are
completely useless at night like
Spider-Man in the middle of a meadow now
you should
did you come up with that
I'll run Spider-Man
stop F you Spidey
if you're gonna now make a a wrist some
kind of physical clock
that is inspired by this amazing time
keeping device called a sundial
then it makes sense that you would track
time
in the same direction like Sundial track
to time exactly
so our clocks are emulated sundials a
mechanical sundials that is so cool
correct all right so this is evidence
that Civilization
that invented sundials did it in the
northern hemisphere right because if it
was the southern hemisphere well clocks
would be running backwards clocks would
be going counterclock counterclockwise
correct and have you seen the
counterclockwise clock in my office
let me go get it it's over there look
mini Neil is holding it I'll be right
back okay
so this is a literal
counterclockwise clock look at that
and
all right you can see it so what time is
it now so it's
uh it looks like it like 401 402 and
running oh that is so creep creepy it's
it's so great it's it's a perfectly
normal clock yeah
It's Perfectly Normal except it's it's
if the southern hemisphere civilizations
invented time
this is what clocks on your wall would
look like that's great
that's really cool that is
trippy yeah it's a little trippy just to
wrap your head around this and there's
nothing weird about it no it's just
weird
it's it's just so out so out of the
ordinary that it that it trips you out
right right wow look at that that's cool
so that's that's why clocks we go
clockwise and then uh we invented
digital time keeping where where there's
just numbers and I remembered when that
came out because that's how old I am I
say wow we don't have to think about
what time it is by looking at hands on a
clock yeah the digits just tell you
and what I found is people started
forgetting how to think of time
geometrically
okay so if it's 12 30
you would and it said it you would say
it's 12 30.
in the old days you say oh it's half
past 12. right quarter till a quarter
two
quarters and halves are geometry of a
circular dial right okay and so that's
why we think 15 minutes is a quarter of
an hour yes it's also that in digital
time but you're not thinking that way
right the way you think of a quarter of
a pizza or a quarter of a circle
so we've lost
think the power to think about time
geometrically I mean some people have
retained it but by and large not but it
also gives a false sense of precision
when I say what time is it it's always
12 33 did I really care that it was 12
33 really was that what I was after I
just wanted to know it's about 12 30.
right so not if you're trying to catch a
train no it's like okay fine but
otherwise okay often when you want it
when you ask someone the time you just
want to know the approximate time but
when it's handed to you digitally you
end up reporting it digitally right and
that's and it becomes unnecessary
Precision in the moment
that's the just a simple Point yeah yeah
and you know I have an analog wristwatch
and and of course you see even the
digital watches today you can put it in
analog mode right yes where you can see
the hand which I like and so now I have
a I have a digital watch that that you
can change the face of I mean
and I have several different watch faces
on here and and most of them are analog
but it's funny that you just said what
you said about the digital precision
I don't use them because when I look
down I want to see numbers you want to
see numbers okay I want to see numbers
now it turns out today everyone does
have the exact time as each other right
and I tweeted a few months ago I said
gone in the era of the smartphone right
gone is the scene
in heist movies
where people Gather in a circle and say
what
all right let's synchronize our watches
it watch this gentlemen
and so anyone in modern times say why
would you do that yeah exactly aren't
they already synchronized with GPS so so
that is such an Antiquated prehistoric
moment in a heist movie that it's it's
almost clean and I say Dan I am that old
aren't I yeah well nowadays it'd be like
all right let's synchronize our watches
and they'd be like what's a watch
synchronize your watches I don't know
how to do that I don't wear a watch time
is a construct but a little
to the youngins out there that
Garrett wrist watches would lose or gain
a minute a day
right the accurate ones was a minute a
week a couple of minutes a month so you
were guaranteed to not match the time of
other people if you're about to commit a
crime and that's why you have people say
what time do you have yes
what time do you have no what time is it
what time is it what time do you have
right and that way that's the time your
own little world and your own little
watch yeah be like oh my God it's 4 30
I'm late oh wait a minute I'll just go
in the kitchen it's only 4 15 in there
friend in college who kept her clock 20
minutes early and I say why do you do
that oh so that way I'm never late don't
you know that it's 20 minutes early
exactly yeah but I still and okay I
couldn't I'm too yeah analytic to
embrace that I just let it go yeah I was
not going to have a conversation about
that
it'd be something different if she had
someone randomly each morning set it
ahead yeah you set my clock ahead I
won't know what time and you don't know
how many minutes or whatever exactly it
could be two minutes ahead it could be
10 minutes it could be 20 minutes
exactly that's right but when you do it
you know it's like hiding your own
Easter eggs
and one last thing in the old days when
they made chronometers that they would
send out to see if you built a very
careful seaworthy chromometer and you
sent it out and it lost a minute a day
you would not take it back to the shop
to fix it
you had a formula correction for it
and you would not mess with it so after
three days it would be slow by three
minutes and you'd correct for that
and so that's how how you got a clock
and took it with you the clock and the
correction formula so you would always
you would always be on on time and On
Cue oh that's yeah that that's
thank God for the phone
[Music]
that sounds like a nightmare or jet
planes right
so I I just wonder in a hundred years
and say all those poor suckers and back
in 2023 they only had GPS and they only
had this and they only had that I think
I lose sleep over wondering how
primitive it is what's going on with us
that when people 100 years hence will
look back and be glad they're not alive
back in these backwards times
or they'll look back and realize God
those guys were actually alive that
ah they all had some semblance of
civilization yeah is that true mommy
daddy is that is that tell me more tell
us about the before four times dad
before we became pets for AI
yeah man who knows children there was a
time when humans controlled artificial
intelligence yeah what
stuff up Dad yeah no that was true we
invented them
all right all right we gotta call it
quits there that's awesome all right
Chuck always good to have you always a
pleasure this has been another Star Talk
explainer Neil deGrasse Tyson here keep
looking up
[Music]